there were no signs it came without
warning
do came to us all
the desperate few struggle
for peace
but desperation try
began a millennium of conflict
thousand dollars
ah
gracious war
has ever known
the reason they fight lost to the ages
and yet here they still sound searching
of peace
damn
I am appalled Ian
I dream war
Oh
oh yes desperation drives us to war it
is trust that can end it apollyon and
her black stone legions crave a world
where Trust is impossible and the Wolves
among us can roam free
I'm Jason Vandenberg I'm the creative
director on fer honor last year in our
multiplayer reveal we gave you the
chance to experience our new melee
combat system the art of battle now we
welcome you to the world of fer honor in
our campaign benighted
join the blackstone legions to drive
your enemies from your lands as a
samurai unite your people to prevent a
civil war and restore the prestige of
the Empire and as a Viking well I think
it's better to just show you I'd like
you to meet what I'd like you to meet
our game director on for honor Roman
camp o Soori ola come on out rolling yes
my brother
like you are the Raider in the aftermath
of war your people were starving you
brought them back now your fleet sails
for the lands of the samurai and seeking
plunder and glory
Paul eons War had taken us to the edge
of extinction but that Raider reminded
us of
we would raid
but not apollyon
not yet but
okay
price
ready your weapon
nerds
I welcome you all
the gates of that fortress hadn't worked
for a century all we had to do
let's get through them
yeah
you
that war was the only way forward
perv
no [ __ ]
roach brothel here
lead the climb
one warrior made it to the top one would
be enough
the Raider got us inside that fort now
we have them
yeah
ha
he's son donaga
cervix some of us will be they were
Hawkeye stir my fortress is lost my
soldiers slaughtered soon I will join
them
you opened the gate now you will pay
that Raider showed us what Vikon fury
could do
the great parade they would call it and
it had begun
Jennifer omen
if you are looking for something to give
that very special someone in your life
for honor will be available on
Valentine's Day yeah sweet it's a nice
gesture what could be more romantic than
dinner drinks and an all-night vendor of
epic warfare I have the Ewell bond
forever
or she'll move out in the morning and if
you're in LA come by the Ubisoft booth
for play for honor now for those of you
watching at home header for honor game
comm to register for the very next alpha
that will come very soon